darf ich mich einmal vorstellen bin 21
jahre alt komme aus kasachstan wohne in
der nähe von berlin
seit dem 25
september ist melina spurlos
verschwunden und damit wir kommen zur
achtung verhandlungen mein name ist
maximilian kieffer und wir beginnen
unsere sendung heute abend mit einem
mysteriösen kriminalfall den wir von
anfang an begleiten melina aus
luckenwalde noch immer fehlt von der
22-jährigen jede spur seit mittlerweile
einem monat melina war nach einer
partynacht mit freunden im park spurlos
verschwunden die ermittler gehen
mittlerweile vom schlimmsten aus haben
ein verfahren wegen des verdachts eines
tötungsdeliktes eingeleitet und unsere
reporterin lilly von der osten hat jetzt
exklusiv mit staatsanwältin hannah u
bahn gesprochen und einblicke in die
ermittlung bekommen
wir haben keine spuren in dem park
gefunden es gibt keinerlei anhaltspunkte
bisher sie ist nicht mehr im park wir
wissen auf welchen wegen sie den park
nicht verlassen hat
wir haben keine anhaltspunkte dafür dass
sie den minute park zu fuß mit dem taxi
oder mit öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
verlassen hat der staatsanwältin urban
macht also klar was die ermittler bisher
alles ausschließen und wir haben uns
dann gedanken gemacht und vor allem vor
ort recherchiert was könnte denn mit
miley melina passiert sein welche
theorie bleibt da noch übrig
[Musik]
taucher im see spürende im park die
polizei hat alles abgesucht und das
ergebnis wir haben keine spuren in dem
park gefunden
keinerlei anhaltspunkte bisher
vieles spricht also dafür dass melina
minute park selbst nichts passiert ist
freunde mit denen melina auf dieser bank
in der nacht feierte erklärten gegenüber
achtung fahndung sie sei gegen 1 uhr 30
alleine fortgegangen und die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt sie ist nicht
mehr den park wir wissen auf welchen
wegen sie den park nicht verlassen
fakt ist in linas fahrrad stand auch
tage nach ihrem verschwinden noch dort
wo sie es immer aber gestellt hat
wenn das fahrrad keine rolle spielt was
dann wir haben keine anhaltspunkte dafür
dass sie den minute tag zu fuß mit dem
taxi oder verkehrsmitteln verlassen hat
einen privaten pkw schließt die
staatsanwaltschaft in unserem interview
aber ausdrücklich nicht aus wurde melina
also in der nacht des 24 september von
ihrem späteren mörder mit dem auto am
park abgeholt
in luckenwalde hält sich das gerücht
dass melina in dieser nacht noch mit
einem unbekannten verabredet gewesen
sein soll
und jetzt brauche die beamten ihre hilfe
und fragen wem ist in der nacht zum 25
september etwas verdächtiges in der nähe
des nuthe parks oder im stadtgebiet in
luckenwalde aufgefallen vielleicht ja
eben mein auto in das melina
eingestiegen ist melina die hatte in der
nacht eine schwarze lederhose und eine
weiße jacke an hinweise an die
staatsanwaltschaft potsdam unter der
telefonnummer 0331 2 0 1 70 und
natürlich bleiben wir an dem
wahlberliner weiter dran und
recherchieren hier auch weiter